Traduttore: Stefano Conti
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Anche se l’argomento di cui vi parlerò
oggi è l’intelligenza artificiale,
voglio iniziare raccontandovi
di qualcosa di molto umano:
il pregiudizio.
Pregiudizio è farsi un’idea
di qualcosa a priori,
senza avere un’esperienza diversa.
Per esempio, io ho i capelli rossi,
e una volta c’era il pregiudizio
che noi che abbiamo i capelli rossi
fossimo cattivi, fossimo dei vampiri,
fossimo dei lupi mannari, e a causa
di questi pregiudizi c’era perfino
chi voleva utilizzare il nostro sangue
per trasformare il rame... in oro.
Esistono pregiudizi di tutti i tipi:
verso gli italiani, verso gli stranieri,
verso i ricchi, verso i poveri;
e, anche se il pregiudizio è generalmente
pensato come qualcosa di negativo,
esistono anche pregiudizi positivi,
come, per esempio,
“gli svizzeri sono tutti puntuali”, o
“le donne scandinave sono alte e belle”.
Un altro pregiudizio molto comune
è che il pregiudizio stesso
sia tipico degli umani, e che le macchine,
che l'intelligenza artificiale,
ne siano immuni.
Ma è proprio vero?
Beh, facciamo un esempio.
La forma di pregiudizio più comune,
quella a cui siamo tutti abituati,
purtroppo, è il razzismo
contro le persone di colore,
che vengono spesso insultate
per il colore della loro pelle.
Siamo tutti tristemente abituati
agli episodi negli stadi,
in cui queste persone vengono paragonate
alle scimmie, gli vengono fatti
versi animaleschi, gli vengono perfino
lanciate banane. Ora, direte voi:
“Cosa c'entra tutto questo
con l’intelligenza artificiale?
Non è che un bel giorno un algoritmo
si metterà a dare delle scimmie
alle persone di colore! Non è che Google,
Apple o Facebook rischierebbero
di mettere in commercio
qualcosa del genere!”.
Beh, invece nel 2015 è successo questo.
Google aveva da poco introdotto una
funzione di categorizzazione automatica
in Photos, la sua applicazione per la
gestione delle immagini, e l'algoritmo
di machine learning ha preso a
categorizzare le persone di colore...
come gorilla.
Non è proprio una bella pubblicità, vero?
E non è neanche un caso isolato.
Face-up, un'applicazione che vi permette
di applicare dei filtri
basati sul machine learning
alle vostre immagini,
è stata fortemente criticata, perché
il filtro che doveva far apparire
le persone più belle, se applicato
sulle persone di colore, le faceva
sembrare più bianche.
LinkedIn, invece, è stata accusata di
sessismo, perché fino a qualche tempo fa,
se voi cercavate nel social network
il nome di una donna, per esempio
“Francesca Rossi”, il motore di ricerca
vi suggeriva “Francesco Rossi”
– quasi a dire che gli uomini andassero
meglio per i lavori delle donne .
Anche un algoritmo analizzato dai
ricercatori dell’Università della Virginia
è stato accusato di sessismo, perché
quando mostravano a questo algoritmo
con una rete neurale
delle scene di persone in cucina,
se mostravano un uomo ai fornelli,
l'algoritmo diceva che c'era una donna.
Ora, che cosa sta succedendo?
L'intelligenza artificiale sta imparando
i nostri lati peggiori?
Ci sono degli algoritmi razzisti,
sessisti, misogini, ignoranti?
O, peggio, tutte queste tecnologie
sono sviluppate da persone
piene di pregiudizi?
Beh, niente di tutto questo. Ma allora
perché succede tutto ciò?
Per capirlo, cerchiamo di capire come
funziona un algoritmo di machine learning.
Immaginiamo di dover
addestrare un algoritmo
a capire che taglia di maglietta
portano i nostri clienti.
Ora, è molto semplice. Se utilizziamo
l'altezza - lasciamo perdere il peso,
così chi ha un po' di pancetta
non si sente in colpa - se una persona
è alta un metro e sessanta porterà una S;
se una persona è alta 2 metri e 10
porterà una L o una XL.
Se noi invece vogliamo addestrare,
per esempio, un algoritmo a capire
a che prezzo vendere un appartamento,
possiamo farglielo correlare
col numero di stanze: più stanze ha
l'appartamento, e più costerà.
Se vogliamo addestrare un altro algoritmo
a capire se in una foto c'è
una motocicletta o un'automobile, possiamo
farglielo correlare col numero di ruote:
se è a due ruote, è una moto; se è
a quattro ruote, è un automobile.
Facile, vero?
Il problema è che tutto questo
non tiene conto di un concetto
molto importante in machine learning,
che è “correlation is not causation”.
Ovvero, la correlazione fra due fatti
non implica per forza
che uno sia la causa dell'altro.
Per capire cosa intendo dire,
guardiamo questo grafico.
Questo grafico ci dice che il consumo
di mozzarella pro-capite in America
è correlato col numero di persone
che si addottorano in ingegneria civile.
Ora, è vero questo? È vero che mangiare
mozzarella ci rende ingegneri migliori?
Beh, naturalmente no. Ma se noi
diamo in pasto questi dati
a un algoritmo di machine learning
e gli chiediamo
di predire quante persone
si addottorano in ingegneria civile,
apparentemente sarà perfettamente
in grado di farlo
– anche se lo farà in base
a un ragionamento completamente sbagliato.
Ora, torniamo indietro al nostro esempio
dell'uomo in cucina.
Nella terza foto è evidente
che ci sia un uomo:
guardiamo com’è vestito, guardiamo
la corporatura, i lineamenti, i capelli.
Ma allora perché l'algoritmo ha deciso
che questa persona fosse una donna?
Beh, perché nei dati utilizzati
per addestrare la rete neurale,
nelle scene in cucina
c'erano quasi solo donne.
E quindi l'algoritmo ha
erroneamente generalizzato che,
se una persona sta in cucina,
allora deve essere una donna.
Questo introduce un secondo concetto
molto importante nel campo
del machine learning, che è
“Garbage In, Garbage Out”.
Se voi utilizzate dei dati sbagliati,
“spazzatura”, che contengono
dei pregiudizi per addestrare
il vostro algoritmo,
l'algoritmo imparerà
un ragionamento sbagliato,
un “ragionamento spazzatura”,
imparerà i pregiudizi contenuti nei dati.
Ora, questo esempio naturalmente
è poco interessante.
A chi può interessare un algoritmo
che ragiona come un uomo degli anni ‘50,
che è convinto che il posto
delle donne sia la cucina?
È un buon articolo per la colonna
delle curiosità di un giornale,
ma niente di più.
Ma se noi immaginiamo un algoritmo
usato nelle aule di tribunale,
e se immaginiamo che questo algoritmo
sia utilizzato per stabilire la pena
da comminare all'imputato; immaginiamo
ancora che l’algoritmo a un certo punto
decida che, in base alle caratteristiche
fisiche dell’imputato, per esempio,
in base ai capelli rossi – allora,
se ho i capelli rossi sono più cattivo,
e quindi mi merito una pena più aspra
– sembra ridicolo,
sembra una distopia quasi.
Ma questo è quello che succede
al giorno d'oggi negli Stati Uniti.
In molti stati americani, infatti,
i giudici sono autorizzati
o addirittura incoraggiati a utilizzare
un algoritmo detto di “risk assessment”,
o valutazione del rischio,
che in base a circa 150 parametri
stabilisce la possibilità che ha
l'imputato di commettere nuovi reati.
I giornalisti di ProPublica, una testata
investigativa americana indipendente,
hanno analizzato 7 mila
di questi punteggi, e guardandoli
si sono accorti che le persone di colore
venivano sistematicamente svantaggiate
da questo algoritmo, ovvero
che l’algoritmo associava la pelle scura
a una maggior possibilità
di compiere nuovamente reati.
Ora, come non è vero che i miei
capelli rossi mi rendono più cattivo,
non è vero che la pelle nera
rende le persone più propense al crimine.
La teoria dell'invarianza della razza,
che ci dice che non sono
le caratteristiche fisiche,
ma le caratteristiche sociali, l'ambiente
in cui uno vive, la situazione economica
a spingere una persona
a compiere atti criminali,
è accettata dalla criminologia moderna.
Ora, purtroppo è anche vero che
nelle carceri americane, in proporzione,
ci sono molte più persone di colore.
Ma questo, appunto, avviene perché
negli Stati Uniti d'America
le persone di colore sono generalmente
più svantaggiate, hanno un minor accesso
all'educazione, sono generalmente
più povere, vivono in un contesto
più svantaggiato.
Ma l'algoritmo, anziché correlare
tutti questi fattori socio-economici,
ha correlato il colore della pelle
alla criminalità, come il peggior razzista
del Ku Klux Klan.
Ora, magari voi non siete donne,
non siete neri, non avete i capelli rossi,
quindi mi dite: “Ma perché a me dovrebbe
interessare tutto questo?”.
Beh, il fatto è che al giorno d'oggi
gli algoritmi sono utilizzati
– il machine learning, l’intelligenza
artificiale – in sempre più ambiti.
Ci sono algoritmi che stabiliscono
se voi potete contrarre un mutuo.
se voi svilupperete una certa malattia.
Ci sono algoritmi che stabiliscono se voi
siete adatti a un certo tipo di lavoro.
E se un algoritmo decidesse un bel giorno
che i biondi non sono adatti
a fare gli agenti di commercio?
O se un algoritmo decidesse,
se l’algoritmo di Facebook decidesse
che le persone che votano un certo partito
– “Beh, i loro post non ci piacciono,
non facciamoli vedere agli altri”.
O se una macchina autonoma decidesse
in una situazione di pericolo
che è meglio prendere sotto
la persona grassa?
Beh, la situazione non è bandire gli
algoritmi o scappare da questi problemi.
Ora, non sta a me dire se Macron
sia un bravo politico o meno,
ma la sua strategia per la Francia
nell’intelligenza artificiale
è sicuramente ammirabile.
Macron vuole che la Francia
sia all'avanguardia in questo ambito,
e si è reso conto che lo sviluppo
dell'intelligenza artificiale
non può che passare per una commistione
fra la mia disciplina
- sono un informatico - e la sociologia,
e la filosofia, e si è reso conto
che questi problemi vanno affrontati
oggi, adesso, subito,
prima che sia troppo tardi.
In Italia, naturalmente, la situazione
è un po' differente.
Esiste la “Carta per i diritti
in internet”, che ci dice
che le decisioni importanti nella vita
di un cittadino non dovrebbero
essere prese esclusivamente da algoritmi.
Dico “dovrebbero”,
perché poi questa dichiarazione
non è stata tradotta in legge – anzi,
lo scorso governo ha anche rifiutato
una moratoria sulle armi automatiche,
continuando a proporre lo studio
delle armi autonome; che, così come
i giudici americani ben possono
venire influenzati dalle decisioni
degli algoritmi,
anche le persone che usano
armi autonome che,
anche se non è l'arma autonoma
a sparare l'ultimo colpo,
possono venire influenzate
dalle decisioni di un’arma autonoma.
Se un missile decide
che quello è un obiettivo,
chi sono io per dirgli:
“No, hai sbagliato”?
Purtroppo, però, su questo tema
negli ultimi mesi
c’è un assordante silenzio
da parte di tutti i partiti.
Eppure, come abbiamo visto, il machine
learning, l’intelligenza artificiale,
ecc. ecc., saranno, sono,
saranno sempre più utilizzati
in tutti gli aspetti della nostra vita.
E noi dovremmo quindi avere il diritto di
capire come funzionano questi algoritmi,
in base a cosa prendono le loro decisioni;
e, quando questo non è possibile --
perché molti algoritmi
sono difficili da comprendere,
è molto difficile da capire
perché fanno delle decisioni --
almeno dovrebbe essere comprovabile
la loro oggettività.
E poi io non so se, come dice qualcuno,
la singolarità, la super-intelligenza
stanno davvero arrivando; ma, quando
arriveranno, vogliamo
che abbiano pregiudizi
contro gli esseri umani?
Grazie.